Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer, had a lot
of capillariessss!
Because #science!
Reindeer are inextricably tied to the Christmas
holiday in the United States.
Santa and his eight reindeer shoot across
the sky like a comet delivering prezzies to
all the good little girls and boys, right?
Well, I don't want to be the donner party
at this show, but reindeer's noses aren't
red OR glowy -- except on the Island of Misfit
Toys, that place is cray.
But, there is some truth to the Rudolph tale,
there's more red in their nose than in cupid's
arrows.
Rudolph was created in 1939 for a children's
book, but a certain species of reindeer, found
in Alaska, Canada, Greenland, Russia and Scandinavia,
REALLY HAVE RED NOSES!
And now research from the journal BMJ explains
WHY!
Those saucy vixens have lots of blood vessels
in there!
Reindeer, on average, have a 25-percent high
concentration of blood vessels in their noses
[25% compared to what?].
Reindeer noses are exposed to the frigid air
of the arctic, and unlike a human dancer,
or dasher who might jump around or run to
get warm -- reindeer need to conserve their
energy.
This species of reindeer uses their nose to
help regulate internal temperatures and to
keep their nose from freezing when they're
rooting around in the frozen tundra looking
for a piece of scrub grass for food.
They discovered this by examining the noses
of reindeer and human volunteers, and then
exercising the reindeer on treadmills.
During exercise their noses and legs shed
lots of heat -- indicating their body was
using all these capillaries to cool themselves,
and, in reverse, to keep their nose warm as
well.
But it's not just the noses of reindeer that
react to the cold, Prancer, oh no.
Reindeer eyes change color as the temperature
falls.
Research out of universities in England and
Norway looked at the eyes of arctic reindeer
and found the tapetum lucidum changes color
depending on the amount of daylight.
The TL is the reflective layer behind the
retina that many animals have to see better
at night -- think cats or dogs when the camera
flash goes off.
In the summer, the reindeer's TL is gold colored,
allowing for the MOST reflection when the
light in the arctic is brightest.
In the winter, when it's FAR darker, the TL
changes color to a deep-blue.
This reflects less light out of the eye and
allows the reindeer to see better!
Scientists believe the color change comes
from the pressure within the eyeball itself.
A properly drained and pressurized reindeer
eyeball is gold, but when darkness persists,
the pupil dilates more.
That perma-dilation increases the pressure
in the eyeball which keeps it from draining
properly.
That presses on the collagen connecting the
TL to the back of the eyeball shifting the
wavelengths reflected by the layer and it
turns a deep blue.
That blue reflection also allows the reindeer
to see ultraviolet light, which humans cannot
see.
That is extra valuable in the darkness of
the arctic winter.